welcome back changes to the way police
apply the use of force policy
could be in the near future yeah we're
talking about a new bill that was
discussed today in the senate committee
that has some state lawmakers shaking
their heads christian joining us live
from the newsroom
with more on who is behind this bill
christian that's right well democratic
state senator dallas harris says sb 212
is still a work in progress but it's all
about modernizing the use of force
policy
still some republican senators said the
bill was unbalanced
and questionable now during the virtual
meeting today harris
said that the current policy only
creates a necessary escalation
lack of community trust and gives the
perception of police control
she added that one in two
officer-involved shootings were fatal in
2019
she used a slide saying reno is one of
seven major cities
where police killed black men at higher
rates than the u.s
murder rate today some republican
senators questioned the bill
and showed a tough stance on the issue i
got to say
that this was an incredibly one-sided
voted presentation
and the fact that our law enforcement
committee is going to be limited to two
minutes to rebut
some of these charges i think is
outrageous
well the bill calls for more limits for
police during
protests and demonstrations requiring
them to give an office
in order to disperse and give sufficient
time for the crowd
to clear the area before deploying using
things like pepper balls now it also
includes a de-escalation
of a situation by forcing officers to
keep a safe distance
when talking to subjects now again
senator harris
stated that this is a work in progress
but it's definitely raising a lot of
eyebrows among state leaders
which will mean that this bill has a
long road ahead
christian casadas 8 news now